The King of Kong documentary proves that video
game scores, and mullets, are a very serious
business. Everyone is out to set a new speedrun
record or high score, so it's hard to keep
up sometimes. You can play Kickle Cubicle
until your thumbs are as thick as your neck
and never come close to the masters' scores,
but at least you'll have a good time doing
it. If getting your name etched into the annals
of gaming history is your thing, you can aim
really high… but there are some records
you'll have a really hard time beating.
TURBO MODE KILL SCREEN IN PAC-MAN
Pac-Man perfection is a combination of robotic
timing, relentlessness, and adult diapers.
The player's goal is to break the game by
reaching the "kill screen." That's a point
in the game's code where the screen decays
into random symbols, the result of a memory
shortage after level 256. Glitching Pac-Man
is the Grail of competitive retro gaming,
officially reached by only seven people. There
are a few modded games and apps floating around
online that can start you off with the kill
screen, but it's not the same as earning it
the hard way. Good luck trying it in Turbo
Mode—only two people in history ever reached
it that way.
FASTEST TIME IN SUPER MARIO BROS.
Over the years, all kinds of players have
scrambled to beat the original Super Mario
Bros. on the NES in record time. Depending
on whether or not you use the Warp Zone pipes
to skip levels, you can have a very different
time for your overall playthrough. In terms
of clearing every level (without warping),
from start to finish, Andrew Gardikis was
able to beat this iconic game in just 19 minutes
and 12 seconds. On top of that, Gardikis holds
the warp zone record as well, beating the
game in just 4 minutes and 57 seconds. Why
bother grabbing the mushroom when you can
just win, right?
MEGA MAN X, X2, AND X3 BEATEN SIMULTANEOUSLY
WITH THE SAME CONTROLLER
The elite Mega Man player known online as
"agwawaf" was able to beat Mega Man X, X2,
and X3 with 100 percent completion in just
43 minutes and 51 seconds. While all three
of those games have faster completion times,
there's a twist to this particular record:
agwawaf was actually playing all three games
at once with a single controller. His gamepad's
inputs were used across all three games simultaneously,
which allowed him to beat them all at once.
Sure, the runs weren't perfect, and he took
damage along the way. But just think of how
incredible it is to beat three games at the
same time in just under 44 minutes. In fact,
all three final bosses, endings, and credits
sequences all happen during his playthrough
at the same time. Most people can't even beat
one of these games in under an hour, let alone
all three at once. Just give up now, you guys.
LONGEST MMORPG GAMEPLAY MARATHON IN WORLD
OF WARCRAFT
Hectaerina Kinumi Iglesias is no stranger
to setting unbreakable records, especially
when it comes to role-playing games. Going
by her online alias of Kinumi Cati, Iglesias
played World of Warcraft for 29 hours and
31 minutes, starting on March 29, 2014, and
finishing the next day. She set two Guinness
World Records in that time: one for the longest
video game marathon on a massively multiplayer
online role-playing game; and the other for
longest video game marathon on World of Warcraft.
She also holds the records for longest video
game marathon in a Japanese-style role-playing
game and longest video game marathon for any
Final Fantasy title, playing Final Fantasy
X for a whopping 38 hours and 6 minutes. And
that's really way too much Wakka for one sitting.
THE LEGEND OF ZELDA EXTREME CHALLENGE
The rules of the Zelda Extreme Challenge are
harsh, like Ganon himself created it to ensure
he ultimately wins. You have to completely
skip getting the sword at the start of the
game—but don't worry. It gets better. You
also can't collect most treasures, you can't
accidentally kill overworld enemies, and you
can only use bombs and fire on bosses. Your
quest ends when you encounter the final boss,
who cannot be defeated without the treasures
you've skipped. While you've certainly accomplished
something, you'll still never know sweet victory.
Only four people have completed the challenge
in both the first and second quest modes.
They didn't save Hyrule, but they've more
than earned our respect.
LONGEST GAMEPLAY MARATHON WITH A CONTROLLER
IN CALL OF DUTY
The Guinness Book of World Records marks 135
hours as the longest gameplay session of Call
of Duty, but it comes with a caveat: the record
holder was allowed to take a 10-minute break
for every hour of play, providing some much-needed
naptimes. While you might think that's cheating,
Guinness had a good reason to allow the breaks:
in a separate attempt to set a gameplay marathon
record, a teenager died while in his 40th
consecutive hour of Diablo 3. Indeed, spending
six days in a nonstop warzone would destroy
anyone's psyche. Mind you, this is the record
for gameplay marathons with a controller in
your hand. For a while, it was the longest
gameplay marathon ever. But you won't believe
what actually surpassed it.
LONGEST GAMEPLAY MARATHON IN JUST DANCE 4
Just hearing about this California school
teacher's video game record is exhausting
enough. Carrie Swidecki broke the aforementioned
Call of Duty record by playing Just Dance
4 on Xbox 360 for 138 consecutive hours. Just
let that sink in for a moment—most people
feel exhausted playing Just Dance 4 for 13
minutes, let alone nearly six days. Swidecki
simultaneously set three world records while
playing a dance game that requires players
to move and just dance the entire time. By
dancing until the 138-hour mark, she set the
world records for longest video game marathon
of all time, longest marathon playing a dance
game, and longest marathon with a motion-sensing
game. Even more impressive? By playing Just
Dance 4, Swidecki dropped 80 pounds and raised
over $7,000 to support children's health-related
charities.
THE WORLD'S LARGEST VIDEO GAME COLLECTION
Michael Thomasson might look like a regular
guy, until you realize he's arguably the most
dedicated hoarder and collector of video games
and consoles that ever lived. In late 2013,
Thomasson won the Guinness World Record for
the largest video game collection. We're talking
10,607 games and over 100 consoles. Thomasson
was able to sell his gargantuan set for over
$750,000, but he's probably going to rebuild.
How did he acquire such a library? Thomasson
has the connections, as he ran seven different
video game stores over the past 20 years and
has been working at several retail game stores
along the way. He even teaches college classes
on retro gaming. Man, what's on the final?
Explaining what the hell Dig Dug was actually
about?
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw.